hey guys it's Jan here I absolutely
loved the epic trailer for Suicide Squad
and quite frankly I cannot wait until
August rolls around and we finally get
to see the worst of the worst up there
in all their glory on the big screen
there's been some crazy reports of what
went down on set during the movie shoot
- so I wanted to look at seven of the
most insane crazy WTF backs so far about
the Suicide Squad movie
according to Ike Barinholtz who's best
known for the Mindy project and the
neighbors movies with Zac Efron and Seth
Rogen Suicide Squad director David Ayers
loved to really mess with his actors
Minds before they start filming telling
them all sorts of crazy stuff to get
them in the dark place he wants them in
for their character Barinholtz who's
Suicide Squad character is yet to be
revealed says that err used a similar
trick on his last movie fury and it very
nearly ended in a fight between Shia
LaBeouf and Jon Bernthal and during Cara
Delevingne audition for Suicide Squad
enchantress David Ayer riled up Donovan
so much that she so she wanted to kill
someone by the time she left
and precisely because err insisted his
actors went into all the traumatic
places they needed to go to really bring
their characters to vivid life the
director had a therapist brought onset
to the cast according to Adam beech who
plays Slipknot in the movie well not
exactly a therapist but a life coach
he's a friend of David Ayers was there
to make sure none of the cast took their
psychotic work home with them as to
Jared Leto who plays the Joker he stayed
in character while filming the entire
movie just as he did for his
oscar-winning turn in the movie Dallas
buyers club Will Smith who plays
Deadshot said that let him never spoke a
single word to Smith as himself during
the whole six-month shoot
according to Suicide Squad producer
Charles Roven Leto isolated himself from
the rest of the cast which actually
helped The Suicide Squad gang to bond
and on top of that letter wouldn't come
to set unless the crew called him mr. J
in fact Jared Leto has taken his method
acting to a whole new level with Suicide
Squad sending his cast mates a bunch of
disturbing gifts letter sent his
stars who were in rehearsals at the time
of video himself in character telling
them he was sorry not to be there but
was working just as hard as they were
for Margot Robbie who's Harley Quinn
character is the Joker's lover in the
comic books letter sent a love letter
plus a box with a live rat inside Will
Smith also got a letter from the Joker
actor but his Wong's accompanied five
bullets and what does a method actor
playing one of DC's greatest villains
get his castmates as a group gift a dead
pig of course Margot Robbie really got
into her crazy Harlequin character as
well setting up her own tattoo parlor
and inking the word squad onto her
co-stars arms Will Smith also had a go
at tattooing Joel Kinnaman who plays
Suicide Squad Leader Rick Flagg however
apparently tattooing isn't one of
Smith's many talents in fact to quote
killerman it was like watching a drunk
baby fly a helicopter but when it comes
to having a blast on set
Will Smith definitely is your man when
an all-night shoot meant the cast and
crew miss the manny pacquiao
Floyd Mayweather fight Smith took care
of business arranging for three cinema
screens to reset up so everyone could
watch the fight the next day during
lunch and on top of that he hired a
restaurant to cater for all 500 peoples
Alan's not content with his boxing match
endeavours Will Smith also pumped up the
volume along with the tempo and threw a
party for the cast and crew including a
special concert with non others and DJ
Jazzy Jeff the guys performed ten songs
together doubtless a good bit of
practice for their 2016 reunion tour so
guys what are you looking forward to
most about Suicide Squad and what kind
of Joe could you think Jared letter is
going to make Plus are there any other
crazy things you've heard about the
movie and its stars I've got more DC and
comic book videos coming up shortly so
do subscribe for those and you can check
out some links here for more of my movie
facts Easter eggs and Comic Con videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers